more than a decade ago bitcoin was
created to solve a very specific
computer science problem the double
spend problem and the creation of a
blockchain and bitcoin ended up kicking
off a monetary revolution but we've
watched central bankers around the world
sit back and see the global adoption of
a decentralized digital currency this
obviously removes the central banker's
control over the supply of money central
banks have always had a monopoly on the
production and distribution of money and
now they're seeing this new technology
and they're trying to figure out how the
hell can they use this new tech to
actually go ahead and cement their
control moving forward that's the
creation of central bank digital
currencies you see them talking about it
studying and even piloting it in various
places around the world central bankers
want to be able to use tokenized money
it's the same fiat currency there's no
change to the monetary policy it's
simply a technology upgrade to the exact
same money and it would put central
bankers in control of your financial
life there's a lot of nasty stuff in
here but before we get into what my
personal thoughts on are
recently joe rogan had a guest on his
podcast that broke this down in great
detail here's a little excerpt to get
you up to speed on exactly what we're
talking about there's the video there's
him speaking about it the g7 is
launching a set of public policy
principles for retail central bank
digital currencies cbdc's
central bank digital currencies could be
a digital version of money a bit like a
digital banknote that could be used
right so that's the guy who runs our
economy in the uk names the chancellor
of the exchequer and here is the article
bank of england tells ministers to
intervene on digital currency
programming yeah and here's a quote from
the article this isn't the telegraph the
one he pulled up but it was behind the
paywall so i'll just read the quote
digital cash could be programmed to
ensure it is only spent on essentials
or goods which an employer or government
deems to be sensible
holy [ __ ] i'm going to take it once now
of course well you've got to go and do
your own research you got to go straight
to the primary source so here's the
exact article that he's talking about
quite literally the title says bank of
england tells ministers to intervene on
digital currency programming and what
you can see is that they're talking
about giving the issuer control over how
it is spent by the recipient this is
what i'm talking about when i say that
nasty [ __ ] is coming to money ultimately
the central bankers will be able to say
who you can transact with what you can
purchase when you can purchase if they
don't like you they don't like your
ideas they don't like past purchases
you've made maybe they think you're fat
you shouldn't buy candy if they think
that you've gambled too much maybe they
won't allow you to pay for the public
transportation to get to the casino this
is totalitarian control over your
financial life if you don't have the
freedom to transact you're not free if
we continue when we look here kobe
making a great point financial sanctions
against citizens in canada may appear to
be an isolated extreme but it is a trend
modern government and central bank
racketeers want to exchange their
freedom for their power surveillance
isn't enough they want to control where
you're allowed to spend your money and
ultimately that's what we're talking
about with central bank digital
currencies we are talking about one of
the greatest violations of human rights
in history this would give central
bankers and their government cronies the
ability to not only see exactly how much
money you have in your account who you
transact with how much you spend on
goods and services when and where but it
would also allow them then to censor
your financial life we don't want a
social credit system we don't want
financial censorship we don't want
personalized inflation and we definitely
don't want money that can expire these
are all ideas that are being floated
around these central bank digital
currencies bitcoin is a decentralized
digital system nobody in the world
controls it nobody can change the rules
without the agreement of majority of the
folks and so ultimately central bank
digital currencies are trying to emulate
some of the technology but do it in a
more centralized authoritarian way we
must be very careful here we must have
this conversation now before it's too
late central bank digital currencies
they're being propagated they're being
presented they're being promoted in a
positive light but there's a lot of bad
stuff that come with it and it's time
that we have that conversation hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time